* Schwebende Orgelklänge *
Ich bin in der russischen
Kulturmetropole Sankt Petersburg.
Vor mir liegt eine Aufgabe, die
mindestens drei Nummern zu gross ist.
Aber wie sagt meine Frau:
Bescheidenheit
ist etwas für Pechvögel.
Zum Abschluss meiner
langjährigen Korrespondentenzeit
möchte ich bei der Weihnachtsmesse
in einem der besten Chöre der Stadt
mitsingen.
Ich, der Laie, inmitten von Profis.
* Inbrünstiger Gesang *
Ein Freund aus alten Tagen
hat mir den Kontakt zum Dirigenten
vermittelt.
Ich dachte anfänglich,
es sei ein kleiner Chor.
Jetzt habe ich herausgefunden:
Es ist ein Chor der Topliga.
Gleich treffe ich den Dirigenten
zum Vorsingen.
Toi, toi, toi.
Wie am ersten Schultag.
Vielleicht ist er nicht zu Hause.
* Knacken *
Seien Sie gegrüsst.
Christof, guten Abend.
Ah, Sie sprechen Russisch.
Ja, mit alpinem Akzent.
Freut mich.
Kommen Sie rein.
Ah, Altbau.
Setzen Sie sich.
Ich bin echt nervös.
Die Geschichte kennen Sie?
Nein.
Das ist Roger, der Regisseur.
Sehr erfreut, Lew.
Freut mich.
Leider spreche ich kein Russisch.
Ich hatte immer den Wunsch,
zu singen.
Ich habe jahrelang Konzerte
für einen kleinen Chor
aus Sankt Petersburg organisiert.
Ich habe immer nur zugehört,
sicher 50- bis 100-mal.
Und da kam der Wunsch auf,
einmal wirklich singen zu lernen.
Jetzt haben Sie die Chance.
Ich kann keine Noten lesen.
Dann lernen Sie es.
Ich dachte, es sei ein kleiner Chor.
Klein, klein, ja.
Jetzt habe ich herausgefunden:
Ihr Chor singt auf höchstem Niveau.
Kommen Sie,
wir versuchen es einfach mal.
* Lew singt fünf
auf- und absteigende Töne. *
Das soll ich nachsingen?
- Ja, so.
Das kann ich nicht.
- Versuchen Sie es!
Ich kann das nicht.
- Bemühen Sie sich!
Auf geht's!
Was soll's, auf geht's!
Schauen Sie, Sie haben es
schon bis zur Note D geschafft.
Das ist die Grundnote
für die Baritonstimme.
Ich denke, Sie haben gute Anlagen,
aber Sie sind nicht entwickelt.
Verstehen Sie?
Ja, ich verstehe.
Man spürt, dass Sie
im Fernsehen professionell sprechen.
Komm, versuch's noch mal!
Jetzt muss ein Plan B her.
- Wieso? Er sagt nicht Nein.
Ja, aber
der gesunde Menschenverstand ...
Deiner?
- Seiner wahrscheinlich auch.
Ich habe ihm erklärt, dass Ihr Chor
in der Champions League singt.
Ich aber bräuchte
höchstens die vierte Liga.
Zuerst einmal
sollten Sie es versuchen,
zumindest einmal
ein Lied in der Baritonstimme.
Eines? Ein Lied.
Oder zwei. Wir werden sehen.
Ich denke, eines reicht.
Nicht nur der Chor auf Topniveau
verunsichert mich,
auch der Ort,
wo alles stattfinden soll.
Die imposante Isaakskathedrale,
einer  d e r  touristischen Hotspots
von Sankt Petersburg.
* Chorgesang *
Jeden Tag singt der Chor
in wechselnder Zusammensetzung
in einem Seitenaltar und begleitet
den orthodoxen Gottesdienst.
Lew, der Dirigent,
hat mich eingeladen, vorbeizukommen.
Ich soll mich
zwischen die Chorsänger stellen,
um ein Gespür dafür zu bekommen.
Ich hoffe bloss,
dass die Chormitglieder,
alles professionelle Sänger, diese
Aktion nicht allzu daneben finden.
Sind Sie zufrieden?
Es klingt sehr kraftvoll.
Hat es Ihnen im Chor gefallen?
- Ja, sehr.
Denken Sie,
es würde Ihnen gelingen, zu singen?
Ja und nein.
Es klingt grossartig,
viel zu gut für mich.
Wie machen wir jetzt weiter?
Darüber müssen wir jetzt nachdenken.
Ja, denken Sie nach!
Worauf habe ich mich da
bloss eingelassen?
Doch der Dirigent
will die Übung noch nicht abbrechen.
Er will mir Noten zum Üben schicken.
Auch die Sänger scheinen kein Problem
damit zu haben, im Gegenteil.
Die Jüngste im Chor hat mich
zu sich nach Hause eingeladen.
Ein Glücksfall,
denn ich möchte wieder einmal sehen,
wie es hinter den Prachtfassaden
von Sankt Petersburg aussieht.
Sie wohnt in einer Kommunalka,
einer Art WG kommunistischer Prägung.
So wohnte ich auch,
als ich vor 25 Jahren
meine ersten
Russland-Erfahrungen machte.
Aber es ist schon sehr lange her,
seit ich das letzte Mal
in einer Kommunalka war.
He! Daria!
Tatsächlich existiert diese Wohnform
in Sankt Petersburg noch oft,
v.a. im Stadtzentrum,
wo die Wohnungen immer teurer werden.
Übrigens:
Auch ein gewisser Wladimir Putin
ist in Sankt Petersburg
in einer Kommunalka aufgewachsen.
Willkommen!
- Danke.
Nett hier, gemütlich.
Hier ist unser Zimmer.
Wir haben
Torten für alle mitgebracht.
Oh, ich habe auch
eine Torte gekauft.
Ah, Sie auch? Das macht nichts.
Wunderbar.
Machen Sie es sich gemütlich.
Haben Sie die Wohnung gekauft?
- Ja, gekauft.
- Also ein Zimmer?
- Ja.
Und einen Balkon.
Sie wollen ihn sicher sehen.
Gerne.
Sehr schön, direkt am Kanal.
- Ja.
Schön.
- Ja, klar.
Darf ich fragen,
wie viel das Zimmer gekostet hat?
1,3 Mio. Rubel.
1,3 Mio.?
Das sind ca. 20'000 Euro.
Früher waren es 40'000,
jetzt sind es 20'000.
Für dieses Geld bekommt man
ausserhalb eine ganze Wohnung,
aber hier im Zentrum
ist es natürlich viel schöner.
Ich finde die Aussicht so schön.
Ich musste sie einfach haben.
Ich will nur hier leben.
* Handy-Klingelton *
Alles gut.
Die Gäste sind schon hier.
Das ist
mein geliebter Frank Sinatra.
Ihr Vorbild?
Ja, er ist mein absoluter Liebling.
Was mögen Sie an ihm?
Alles.
Sein Charisma, die Stimmlage,
die Musikalität, sein ganzes Werk.
Er ist ein einmaliger Musiker.
Und er ist so schön.
* Vokal-Jazz-Song: "Night and Day"
von Frank Sinatra & Tommy Dorsey *
# Like the beat beat beat
of the tom tom.
# When the jungle shadows fall.
# Like the tick tick tock
of the stately clock.
# As it stands against the wall.
Daria und ihr Ehemann Ivan
teilen sich die Kommunalka
mit 16 Menschen
und einem Dutzend Haustieren.
Die Kommunalka hat zwölf Zimmer,
ein Bad und zwei Küchen.
Wir möchten gerne
mit Ihnen sprechen.
Wir haben doch abgemacht,
dass du mich warnst,
bevor die Leute kommen.
Da hast du mich aber in eine
unangenehme Situation gebracht.
Schau, wie ich aussehe!
Das ist doch nicht schlimm.
Alles bestens.
Marina wohnt hier ... seit wann?
- 1986.
Interessant! Erzählen Sie uns doch,
wie es zu Sowjetzeiten war.
Ach, es war genau so wie heute.
Hat sich nichts verändert?
Nein, bloss ein Badezimmer
gab es damals noch nicht.
Gab's nicht?
- Nein.
Was war anstelle des Bades?
- Gar nichts.
Wo hat man sich gewaschen?
Hier in der Küche
hat man die Kinder gebadet.
Wir stellten eine kleine Wanne hin
und kochten Wasser,
weil es damals nur kaltes gab.
Wir passen uns dem Leben an.
Wir finden für jede Situation
einen Ausweg.
Können Sie uns
das Badezimmer zeigen?
Es sieht schrecklich aus.
Ganz schrecklich.
Das macht nichts.
Ich hatte früher auch so eines.
Ein Badezimmer für alle?
Ja, und es ist wirklich schlimm.
Man müsste einen Helm tragen.
Macht nichts. Was ist da oben?
Das ist
eine einsturzgefährdete Wohnung.
Damit die Leute vom vierten Stock
nicht plötzlich
in unserer Wanne liegen,
haben wir diese Stützen installiert.
Da gehst du duschen und plötzlich
fängst du den Nachbarn von oben auf.
In diesem Badezimmer
will man sich nicht lange aufhalten.
Deshalb haben wir auch nie
eine Schlange vor dem Bad.
Drei Torten haben wir also.
* Jazzmusik *
* Jubelrufe *
Von welcher Torte möchten Sie?
Egal.
- Karamell oder Kognak?
Ja, dann Kognak.
Das ist mein Ehemann.
Freut mich.
Als ich vor 25 Jahren hier ankam,
konnte ich
nur einen Satz auf Russisch:
* Er spricht russisch. *
Danke für Ihre Gastfreundschaft.
Dieser Satz passt auch heute noch.
Während Daria
heute Nacht noch ausgeht,
heisst es für mich vorerst
Abschied nehmen von Sankt Petersburg.
* Jazz-Song: "The Way You Look
Tonight" von Frank Sinatra *
# Cause I love you
and the way you look tonight.
Die Noten vom Dirigenten
sind noch nicht gekommen.
Dafür sind meine Zweifel zurück.
Aber kaum angefangen,
kann ich nicht schon wieder aufgeben.
Zum Glück habe ich zu Hause
professionelle Unterstützung.
Meine Tochter Maria
ist ein Gesangstalent.
Mit alten russischen Liedern
sorgte sie in einem Talentwettbewerb
im russischen Fernsehen für Furore.
* Heiterer Klang *
Marias Gesangslehrerin Marina
muss mir helfen.
Zurück in Moskau,
wo ich seit zehn Jahren lebe,
treffe ich mich mit ihr.
Sie machen aus mir einen Sänger.
- Einen Sänger.
Einen Bariton.
Wir werden uns Mühe geben.
Maria sagt, ich müsse aus dem Bauch
singen und nicht aus dem Kopf.
Ja, die Atmung.
Genau,
aber ich muss bei Null anfangen.
Die erste Gesangsstunde
meines Lebens.
Und das in einem Studio
namens Jimi Hendrix.
Schon ziemlich eigenartig das Ganze.
Also, wie lange
können Sie einen Ton halten?
Das weiss ich nicht.
Los! Nehmen Sie einen beliebigen Ton
und den Laut A
oder einen, der Ihnen genehm ist.
* Er singt. *
- So?
- Ja, einfach einen beliebigen Ton.
Ich kann sehr lange.
Ich habe riesige Lungen.
Na, dann zeigen Sie mal!
* Er singt
einen lang anhaltenden Ton. *
Irgendwie so?
Unfassbar! So lange!
Das ist sehr lange.
Ich habe ein Lungenvolumen
wie ein Spitzensportler,
sagte einst ein Arzt, von Natur aus.
Können Sie jetzt versuchen,
so zu singen,
dass der Ton nicht schwankt?
Also ohne Vibrato.
Am besten,
Sie machen es an der Wand.
Stellen Sie sich vor,
Sie würden die Wand bewegen.
Ja, mit den Händen dorthin.
Bewegen Sie sie!
Oh, ich habe richtig Angst.
Aber sie bewegt sich nicht.
Man hat das Gefühl,
Sie hätten Angst, sie zu bewegen.
Sie müssen sie
wie einen Schrank wegschieben.
Jetzt ist er gerade,
jetzt ist der Ton richtig.
Sie haben richtig dosiert,
wie es Sänger tun.
Das machen Sie schon ganz gut.
Immerhin etwas.
- Ja.
Sagen Sie,
wem haben Sie vorgesungen?
Vielleicht kennen Sie ihn.
Ich denke eher nicht.
Er ist Dirigent,
manchmal auch am Mariinsky Theater.
Als Sie ihm vorgesungen haben,
was hat er Ihnen gesagt?
Was hat er Ihnen gesagt?
Er sagte, ich sei ein Bariton.
Da hat er Ihnen aber
eine schwierige Aufgabe gegeben.
Bariton befindet sich in der Mitte
zwischen der hohen Männerpartie
und der ganz tiefen.
Ist das schwierig?
Das ist die schwierigste Aufgabe,
weil es genau zwischendrin ist.
Die höheren und tieferen Stimmen
haben Melodien,
das ist einfacher.
Aber für das dazwischen
braucht man ein sehr gutes Ohr.
Dass er Ihnen eine solche Aufgabe
gegeben hat, bedeutet,
dass er entweder
sehr stark an Sie glaubt,
oder aber ...
... es ist ihm egal.
Die Lektion
hat mich körperlich geschafft,
aber ich habe viel gelernt
und bin motiviert.
Doch die Noten
sind immer noch nicht gekommen.
Vom Dirigenten habe ich seit
meinem Vorsingen nichts mehr gehört.
* Sanfte elektronische Klänge *
Ich habe beruflich
in Sankt Petersburg zu tun.
Vielleicht kann ich
den Dirigenten kurz treffen.
Indes: Lew ist vielbeschäftigt
und oft unterwegs im In- und Ausland.
Es ist mir irgendwie unangenehm,
ihn zu stören.
Vielleicht will er ja gar nicht mehr,
dass ich an Weihnachten mitsinge.
Trotzdem: Es ist für mich
immer wieder eine Freude,
in der ehemaligen Hauptstadt zu sein.
Willst du auch einen?
Ich sage nicht Nein.
Einen süssen.
Früher ass ich immer Shawarma.
Eine Kollegin
behauptete tatsächlich,
es könnte Menschenfleisch drin sein.
Man solle es auf keinen Fall
auf der Strasse essen.
Kannst du dir das vorstellen?
Das war in den 90ern.
Was für eine Sendung machen Sie?
Aus der Schweiz
über Sankt Petersburg.
Klasse.
Kommen Sie von hier?
- Ja.
Wie gefällt Ihnen die Stadt?
- Hervorragend.
Und was besonders?
Die Schönheit und die Ruhe.
Die Ruhe?
Besser als in Moskau.
- Ah, ja?
Können wir ein Foto machen?
- Klar.
Sehr schön!
Darf ich fragen,
wann Sie geboren sind?
1993.
Ernsthaft?
Da kam ich zum ersten Mal hierher.
Damals, 1993,
hatte ich natürlich keine Ahnung,
dass ich dereinst als Korrespondent
aus dem Riesenreich berichten würde.
Ich wollte eigentlich
nur zwei Wochen bleiben,
etwas Russisch lernen.
Ich blieb vorerst für zwei Monate.
Das Russland-Virus
hatte mich gepackt,
obwohl die Verhältnisse damals
kurz nach dem Ende der Sowjetunion
äusserst prekär waren.
Nicht zu vergleichen mit dem
blühenden Sankt Petersburg von heute.
Doch Sankt Petersburg
hatte schon immer
eine sehr wechselvolle Geschichte.
Obwohl noch heute
viele Bürger der Stadt
in eher ärmlichen Verhältnissen
leben,
prosperiert die Metropole,
in der 5 Mio. Menschen wohnen.
Es wird viel gebaut.
Bei Dirigent Lew
immer noch Funkstille.
Dafür treffe ich Alexej.
Der einzige Sänger im Chor,
der noch einen Nebenjob hat.
Er ist Immobilienmakler.
Heute will er
einer Frau und ihrem Sohn
eine 1-Zimmer-Wohnung verkaufen.
Was kostet hier 1 m2?
Fertig ausgebaut 1'600 Euro.
Sind Sie wegen der Wohnung hier?
Guten Abend.
- Guten Abend.
Ist das das tolle Viertel,
das Sie uns zeigen wollten?
Wenn wir es uns anschauen wollen,
müssen wir los,
solange es noch hell ist.
Los geht's!
Schauen Sie sich
das Viertel einmal an
und vergleichen Sie es mit dem,
das Sie kennen,
in dem Sie selber leben,
und mit dem Zentrum.
Das ist schon hübsch.
Was sind Ihre Eindrücke?
Sie sind ja das erste Mal hier.
Bunt, angenehm.
Es ist ganz ähnlich wie in Europa.
Ja, Europa.
Ein bisschen wie in Deutschland.
Wissen Sie,
dieses Viertel heisst Wien.
Es ist der österreichischen
Hauptstadt nachempfunden.
Der österreichischen Hauptstadt.
Das Neubauviertel liegt
etwa 50 Min. vom Zentrum entfernt
und soll eine grösser werdende
Mittelschicht ansprechen.
Insgesamt gefällt es mir.
In einer Musterwohnung
will Alexej seine Kunden
restlos von einem Kauf überzeugen.
Ist es schwierig,
hier eine Wohnung zu finden?
Im Prinzip nein.
Man hat eher die Qual der Wahl.
Es ist schwierig,
sich zu entscheiden,
weil es sehr viele Angebote gibt.
Mehr Angebot als Nachfrage also?
Ja.
- Ja.
Wieso gibt es so viele Angebote?
Hat man zu viel gebaut?
Oder ist die Nachfrage gesunken?
Man hat viel gebaut,
als die Wirtschaft rund lief.
Jetzt ist die Wirtschaft rückläufig,
und die Nachfrage
ist zurückgegangen.
Schauen wir uns
die Küche und den Balkon an.
Oh, eine schöne grosse Küche.
Schauen Sie: Der Balkon
ist oben und unten aus Glas.
So haben Sie viel Sonnenlicht.
(Kunde) Wir denken darüber nach
und rufen dann an.
Vielen Dank.
Morgen telefonieren wir noch mal.
Wieso verkaufen Sie Wohnungen
und singen nicht nur?
Immer nur dasselbe machen,
darf man nicht.
Stellen Sie sich vor:
Sie sitzen bei Tisch und haben nur
Torte, Schokolade, Kekse und Tee,
sonst nichts.
Wenn die Seele singt,
ist das etwas sehr Leckeres, Süsses.
Aber wenn das Mittagessen
bloss aus Süssigkeiten besteht
und es nie Fleisch gibt,
nie Gemüse ...
D.h., Makler sein, ist das Fleisch?
- Ja, das ist das Fleisch.
Später erfahre ich, dass Alexej
die Wohnung verkaufen konnte.
Ich bin zurück im Zentrum.
Mir ist etwas Peinliches passiert
und ich muss
den Dirigenten Lew anrufen.
Ja, guten Abend Lew,
hier ist Christof.
Rufe ich nicht zu spät an?
Wie geht's Ihnen?
Danke für die Noten.
Entschuldigen Sie,
es gab ein Missverständnis.
Ich habe in Ihrer E-Mail
nur das Wort Bariton gelesen.
Dass weiter unten
noch die Noten waren,
habe ich vor drei Wochen übersehen.
Ich habe sie einfach nicht gesehen.
Ich wollte Sie fragen:
Sind Sie morgen am Arbeiten?
Ah, Sie fliegen weg.
Und wann fliegen Sie weg? Früh?
Ah, schon um 7 Uhr morgens.
Entschuldigen Sie bitte!
Okay, dann bleiben wir in Kontakt.
Vielen Dank.
Hat er keine Zeit morgen?
- Er verreist morgen früh um 7 Uhr.
Er hat geschlafen.
Meine Zeit zum Üben
ist eh schon knapp.
Durch meinen Fauxpas
habe ich drei Wochen verloren.
Und Lew kann mir jetzt
auch nicht helfen.
Neuer Tag - neues Glück.
Daria von der Kommunalka und
ihr Ehemann haben spontan zugesagt,
mit mir die Noten einzustudieren.
Schau, das ist unser Part!
Siehst du, das ist Lews Fassung.
Die hat er mir geschickt.
Stell dir vor, ich sei dein Schüler.
Ich verstehe gar nichts. Ich
weiss nicht, wo meine Stimme ist.
Muss ich den Text lesen oder singen?
Er sagt immer: "Übe Bariton!"
Wo ist der Bariton überhaupt?
Das ist Bass.
Der Bass teilt sich auf
in Bass und Bariton.
Denkst du, das kann man lernen,
ohne die Noten zu kennen?
Nein. Es wird ein langer Weg.
Reichen zwei Monate?
Ja, natürlich.
Wieso blätterst du nicht um?
Entschuldigung. Wo bist du?
Es ist ein sehr einfacher Part.
- Einfach?
Das Einfachste vom Einfachen.
Wenn ich singe,
muss ich dann so stehen oder so?
Das ergibt sich von selbst.
Das ist im Moment
unsere kleinste Sorge.
* Sie singen "Stille Nacht". *
Oh!
- Schon gut.
Das ist schwierig mit Noten.
Bitte noch mal!
Gefällt es dir?
- Nein.
Ein klares Urteil der jungen Profis.
Eigentlich ist "Stille Nacht"
ja ein einfaches Lied,
doch diese ungewohnte Baritonstimme
überfordert mich.
Aber in Russland habe ich gelernt,
zu kämpfen.
Und als Bergler ist mir eine
gewisse Sturheit in die Wiege gelegt.
Und so übe ich, wann immer ich neben
meinem Korrespondentenjob Zeit finde.
Auf dem Weg zu einer
Veranstaltung mit Oppositionellen.
Im Kurzurlaub
in den Schweizer Bergen.
Am Polarkreis bei der Einweihung
einer Gasfabrik mit Präsident Putin.
Oder zu Hause in Moskau
mit meiner Tochter Maria.
* Zweistimmiger Gesang *
Hurra!
Jetzt wird sich zeigen,
ob Dirigent Lew auch zufrieden ist
mit meinen Fortschritten,
ob er mich mitsingen lässt.
Sehen Sie, es ist gar nicht so
schwierig, wie es anfangs schien.
Nun ja.
Wenn Sie im Chor singen,
erinnern Sie sich daran,
was ich Ihnen jetzt sage.
Ein Mensch, der in einem Chor singt,
kann nicht unglücklich sein.
Mag es auch
weihnachtliche Milde von Lew sein,
jedenfalls steht meinem Auftritt
jetzt nichts mehr im Wege.
Es ist der 6. Januar,
Heiligabend in Russland,
wo man nach dem julianischen Kalender
Weihnachten feiert.
Nicht einmal in der nördlichsten
Millionenmetropole der Welt
liegt Schnee.
Die Menschen haben frei
und sind in Partylaune.
Und ich mache mich
an die letzten Vorbereitungen.
Hat sich dein Unterfangen gelohnt?
Das Singen?
Und all die Anstrengungen
der letzten Monate?
Ja,
ich habe ein neues Hobby entdeckt.
Früher hatte ich
viel mit Sängern zu tun,
auch wegen der Tourneen,
die ich organisierte.
Ich sang oft mit ihnen
und hatte dabei das Gefühl,
die singen einfach.
Erst nach ein paar Gesangslektionen
merkte ich,
dass mehr dahinter steckt,
auch körperlich.
Es gibt mir Energie.
Das ist sehr eindrücklich.
Aber was rede ich da?
Aber wenigstens weiss ich,
dass ich Stimmbänder besitze,
die auch müde werden können,
dass es eine Muskulatur ist, die
man über Jahre trainieren müsste.
Aber wenn ich wie heute
links und rechts von mir
eine solche Harmonie höre,
das ist so schön
wie ein Glockenspiel.
Meine Lehrerin hat mir geschrieben,
schau mal:
"Frohe Weihnachten.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen."
"Es wird heute alles gelingen.
Viel Glück."
Das schreibt deine Lehrerin?
Schön, nicht wahr?
- Ich hoffe, sie behält recht.
Sie glaubt daran.
Das ist unser Motto.
Kommt schon gut.
- Kommt schon gut.
* Er singt. *
Etwa um 23.30 Uhr
soll die Weihnachtsmesse beginnen.
Genau weiss man das in Russland nie.
Ich bin jedenfalls früh genug hier.
* Spannende Klänge *
Oh, jetzt habe ich mich
wieder nicht bekreuzigt.
Mindestens 2 1/2 Std.
dauert die Mitternachtsmesse.
Das Lied, bei dem ich mitsingen darf,
kommt erst ganz am Schluss.
Meine Lehrerin sagte,
ich müsse mich gut einsingen.
Gar nicht so einfach hier.
Nicht hier!
Lassen Sie ihn,
er hat gleich seinen Auftritt.
Nur ein bisschen.
* Er singt einen ansteigenden Ton. *
* Seine Stimme kratzt. *
Oh je!
Nach knapp 2 Std.
während der Heiligen Kommunion
eine Pause für die Sänger.
Gleich bin ich dran.
Vieles hier erinnert mich
an eine katholische Messe
zu Hause in den Walliser Bergen.
* Chorgesang *
* Sphärische Klänge *
Wo singen die Baritone?
Pascha singt Bariton.
* Er räuspert sich. *
"Stille Nacht"
in einem Arrangement von Lew Dunajew.
Ich gratuliere.
- Danke.
Frohe Weihnachten.
- Danke, Ihnen auch.
Vielen Dank,
dass ich mitsingen durfte.
Es war wundervoll. Mein Traum.
Hat alles geklappt?
- Ich denke, ja. Störte ich nicht?
Sie haben geholfen.
- Das ist das Wichtigste, danke.
Hat es geklappt?
- Danke, das müssen Sie beurteilen.
Ich habe nichts gehört.
Wichtig war, dass ich nicht störe.
- Nein, es war sehr gut.
Daria, frohe Weihnachten.
Gleichfalls.
- Ich danke Ihnen.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nicht gestört.
Ich bitte Sie.
Zu Hause alles in Ordnung?
- Natürlich.
Liebe Grüsse an Ihren Mann.
Danke, dass Sie mich
damals gerettet haben.
Der Chor möchte Ihnen das schenken.
Eine Tasse
mit dem Bild der Isaakskathedrale.
Gut verpackt für den Transport.
Danke vielmals.
Ich werde diese Nacht nie vergessen.
So endet mein weihnachtliches
Abenteuer mit einem Happy End.
Und irgendwie
ist diese Geschichte sinnbildlich
für meine ganze Zeit in Russland.
Ein paar Misstöne,
aber alles in allem wunderschön.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Mein anderes Russland"
fahre ich nach Sibirien
zum Baikalsee.
Dort gibt es
eine Insel namens Olchon.
Sie soll voller Energien
und Kraftorte sein.
Jedenfalls zieht sie
Sinnsuchende aus aller Welt an.